Going back to our browser, we'll refresh the page and
see here that only a single chart was drawn.
And before we finish with this bar chart, I just wanted to point out some of
the benefits of using a high-level library like Dimple.
If you notice, by hovering over a bar, we can see both the date and
attendance of the game.
And we get this horizontal bar that gets animated out.
The tooltip's great,
because it gives us a much finer look into the actual values of our data.
And the horizontal bar the projects out is useful if we want to compare
one bar to all the others and see if its value's greater or less than.
Are there any things that look off with this plot?
Or possibly things that could be improved?